Bonjour tout le monde
Il y'a quelques jours j'ai sorti une vidéo qui s'appelle "Les inventions imaginaires 2"
Alors je suis hyper content parce qu'elle vous a particulièrement plu
Sauf qu'au bout de 24 heures Youtube a décidé de la soumettre à une limite d'âge
A cause d'une scène où on entend un gémissement féminin pendant un acte sexuel pendant, à peu près,
Trois secondes.
*toussote*
Voilà.
J'ai quand même fait une réclamation auprès de Youtube, parce que je trouvais qu'ils exagéraient un tout petit peu
et ils m'ont répondu quoi déjà ?
Ils m'ont répondu  :
"On s'en bat les couilles !"
Voilà !
C'est assez étrange vu que j'avais déjà fait 10 000 fois ce genre de scènes de sexe sur Youtube dans le passé
et j'avais jamais eu de problèmes
A part avec mon ex
Je trouve que le nouveau réglement de Youtube est quand même de plus en plus strict
et c'est assez dommage pour la liberté d'expression
*Euh*
Ne me censurez pas parce que j'ai dit ça !
J'adore Youtube !
J'adore le règlement !
Je l'ai lu
huit fois
En tous cas, vu que cette vidéo vous a beaucoup plu et que j'en suis assez fier
Je trouvais dommage qu'elle soit inaccessible à plein de gens à cause d'une restriction d'âge,
du coup j'ai remonté une nouvelle version sans cette scène pour que tout le monde puisse la voir
Je vous laisse donc apprécier cette nouvelle version de la vidéo et nous on se revoit très bientôt
Ciao !
Allo ! Ouais je suis producteur, ouais
Bonjour !
Voici la suite de ma vidéo sur les inventions imaginaires
C'est-à-dire les inventions qui n'existent pas mais qui pourtant seraient très pratiques au quotidien
comme par exemple
une vitre électrique anti mecs qui parlent trop près du visage
Moi je suis un très très grand fan de Martin Scorsese,
Primo la réalisation
Secondo y'a un plan-séquence d'une minute 47 et là tu vois que c'est un truc de malade parce que...
Oh !
Eh mais c'est quoi ça ?
Il faut que tu parles dans le micro
La réalisation je te disais de Scorsese
Un accélérateur d'histoires chiantes
Et donc l'entomologie c'est la science des insectes, eh, c'est vachement intéressant
Est-ce que t'as déjà vu les petits poils là sur les papillons ?
Quand tu les caresses mais que c'est...
C'est comme ça que je suis devenu Bouddhiste
Ah d'accord !
Super histoire c'est cool
Et tu sais pourquoi  je  suis devenu Bouddhiste ?
Est-ce que t'es déjà allé en Inde ?
Les temples ils sont magnifiques ils sont cool...
Un détecteur de l'origine d'une mauvaise odeur
Très pratique pour ces gens qui se lâchent sans pression en public
L'odeur de prout provient de cet homme
*toussote*
C'est lui !
FAUX.
Un anticipateur de postillons
En ce moment je suis sur une BD super chouette
ça s'appelle
"Vaisseau sssuper spatial"
Et un moment il y'a des vaisseaux qui se tirent dessus
et ça fait
PAN !
PSSAAA, PAN, PAN, PCHIW, PCHIW
Une montre qui permettrait de disparaître dans les moments gênants
ça va les mecs ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est que cette 'zic de merde là ?
Euh, c'est notre groupe
Je suis le guitariste
Je suis le chanteur
Un transformateur de films chiants en films cools
Bon, ça existe déjà
ça s'appelle la beuh , hein mais, FAUT PAS FUMER
beaucoup
Dans les moments où tu sais pas trop quoi répondre à quelqu'un
une télécommande qui te permettrait d'avoir une seconde chance de répartie
Norman, le Youtuber
le mec fait plus de vidéos, on est à le retraite Monsieur ?
Bah non, je suis pas à la retraite
au contraire je fais.. 'fin.. plein de vidéos, je, 'fin..
*soupir*
Ouais je suis à la retraite ouais,
un peu comme tes cheveux
Bon, là j'ai une tête de South Park
parce que j'ai complètement oublié de filmer ce plan avec ma caméra
Ouais je suis, je suis un peu con
l'invention suivante ça serait un détecteur d'endroit où ça gratte dans le dos
Alors gratte-moi latitude 16 et longitude
25 !
O-K
*cri de satisfaction*
Nickel !
Une batterie d'iPhone illimitée
Bon, en même temps ça existe hein, ça s'appelle un
un fil
un Wikipédia automatique dans le cerveau
Tu l'as vu "Le Parrain" ?
Ah oui ! Tu veux dire ce film réalisé par Francis Ford Coppola
produit par les studios Paramount, sorti le 15 Mars 72, et inspiré du roman éponyme de Mario Puzo ?
Bah ouais c'est ça
T'en as pensé quoi ?
Je l'ai pas vu
Mais j'ai adoré
Un flouteur de zones, que t'as pas envie de regarder
"Si elle savait que je lui ai flouté le décolleté pour pas être tenté de le regarder
je vais passer pour un gentleman !"
J'ai envie de me faire greffer
euh, des yeux bridés
"Olala s'il savait que je l'ai entièrement flouté et que j'entends même pas ce qu'il dit"
"Huh quel bolosse !"
un Adblock à blagues pas marrantes
Et tu connais l'histoire de Toto qui rentre dans un bar ?
C'est l'histoire d'un Chinois, d'un prêtre et d'un Boomerang
Dix camion !
Tire sur mon doigt !
ça c'est pas mal quand même
Ce serait vraiment pratique pour les mecs pas marrants
Donc, je disais
*toussote*
Donc, ouais, je disais
Ouais non en fait, c'est pas une bonne idée
Un détecteur de potentiel de chances avec les meufs
Alors, elle, 30%, non.
Elle, 0%, c'est mort elle est avec un mec
Ah, elle 98%, OK, je me lance !
Excuse-moi, je veux pas te déranger mais je vois que t'aimes les même Chips que moi
C'est marrant, je me suis dit que
peut-être qu'on pourrait aller, euh,
*toussote*
qu'on pourrait aller boire un verre et, parler du fait qu'on aime les mêmes Chips et c'est tout, 'fin
Laisse tomber en fait
Et enfin ce qui serait absolument génial, ce serait une invention qui,
lorsque vous aimez la vidéo, mettrait directement un pouce en l'air
ça,
ça, ce serait énorme
Ou alors,
vous pouvez le faire à l'ancienne
A bientôt !